it's just a joke it's ridiculous I think  you're doing something quite complicated  uh sort of mental arithmetic to make it  to offset the fact that people didn't  think you were funny I think the reality  is  these students saw me performing a top  secret comedy club one of the best  companies  okay whoever pays the piper calls the  tune if you're a really good comedian  you can be funny without being offensive  one minute later oh kind of joke do you  feel funny I find really offensive humor  very funny person you do I like really  really I'm outrage on a university event  you can't have jokes about being gay or  being trans or about ethnicity